et maintenant
à
m
si maria pacôme
non
plus bas
my back home bonsoir
parce que tu disais je voulais pas
qu'ils le prennent mal géré sans voler
quand tu penses à navès djamel ouais
enfin ceci étant le décor il est mieux
depuis que tu l'as nick et moi je
traverse tout de suite oui si tu pouvais
pas partir maria pacôme rebond soir
alors je vois qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus roger hart qui vous habille de même
car noël qui vous des corps vous êtes
plutôt habillé comme un cas comme un
journaliste journalistes en irak de la
baisse de 2 journalistes 800 articles
amendés petit gilet mois correspondants
de guerre un petit peu là le look ça va
maria bien bien alors donc j'étais à la
fiche de mauvais esprit de patrick
alessandrin avec thierry lhermitte
ophélie winter clémentine célarié michel
muller je cite attaché de presse est
toujours inscrite gavard je sais pas si
elle est en coulisses catherine laurence
astrid et l'a donc un street surveille
et si des fois je parlais pas c'est bien
du du film mauvais esprit tu pourrais
venir voilà alors légèrement
elle est sûrement la dernière c'est que
c'était mon assistante astres et demi
mais je sais tu m'as vu avec la gaule du
matin
elle m'avait pas dit ça je peux vous
dire en tous les cas que j'ai toujours
respecté à elle m'a pas dit ça non plus
alors le pitch black death est très
simple le film les esprits c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui n'a vraiment pas
de pot dans la vie qui est incarné par
michel muller jusqu'au jour où rumeurs
renversé par une voiture conduite par
thierry lhermitte et il va renaître dans
la peau du bébé que thierry lhermitte va
avoir avec ophélie winter et il est prêt
à tout pour se venger bref c'est une
espèce de chien on est comme on dit sur
les affiches du film c'est une
excellente idée de vraiment c'est un
film très très bonne idée c'est le genre
de scénarii que les américains nous
rachète en général parce que c'est
vraiment c'est très fort la
réincarnation du ch dans le bébé alors
évidemment chaque fois qu'il voit
thierry lhermitte tu le détestes si vous
mettez alors alessandra avait déjà fait
15 août que tu as un bon film 15 août il
ya toujours des relations des bonnes
idées
alors vous vous êtes la mer donc de
thierry lhermitte la belle-mère de
félines winter et vous êtes appelés à un
mouvement à la rescousse pour contrôler
cet affreux db williams on regarde bien
oui les deux monstres est d'ailleurs oui
il ya trois mois il ya le petit alors
oui mais c'est ça qu'est ma tante et
d'ailleurs qui m'a fait que vraiment au
fil immunitaire c'est une horreur là moi
je suis une horreur on se traite mais
comme mais vraiment c'est assez vrai ce
serait qu'un et des rapports n'ya pas
y'a pas un sourire las des rapports
d'une violence entre bwin coeur et vous
elmer et vu qu'il n'existe pas jamais
non jamais moi je connais pas peu
violent c'est très très violent mais
alors on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
tu n'en parles